okay
the next game vegeta
from uh this is belgium i guess yeah
got an old indian
setup i have no idea about this line
recently
a book has been published about exactly
this
this variation knight g4
knight g5 i guess is the main move this
is very complicated
i try to to play simple moves
after all if you think of this
as a french defense reversed colors some
white moves look um the black moves
actually um
look a little bit slow if you ask me
okay
of course i could i could push on the
queen side
one thing um
that my position really um
has gotten in its favor is that i
haven't cast that yet
so he won't get the automatic attack
often
seen in this king's indian attack
positions with colors reversed
and i'm pretty quick on the queen side
i think
we now place d5 i have c6
and then knight e5 which looks awful i
think
but i also have huge pressure on d6
okay what to do now
i think first taking can't be
can't be wrong maybe i had i could have
played 95 immediately
maybe
i expect queen e6 now
some move like this
okay what about the stupid looking move
queen before
just to really get onto this
pawn what does it do then
d5 simply go to d6 and win material
and i don't see how it covers this
okay he wants to cover it with a
to f8
hmm
do i have some some trick there knight
takes
bishop f8
doesn't doesn't look like it
hmm
that's that's too bad
yes
i simply assembly didn't pay attention i
haven't canceled you can just take
anyone
wow okay i really
i really have to take on d5 first
i have knight c7 it's not the end of the
world i guess
queen f6
i hope to have
98 then
bishop c3 check king f1 bishop takes b4
takes their
ridiculous line but i have to take it
okay
yeah now i need to castle
okay i'm one pawn down but
d6 is still hanging i hope he doesn't
get a really
dangerous attack going here it's
certainly possible that he that he does
but
surprised the team really can do this
but okay
now he has to take with the pawn in
order to
to keep keep this covered
black's position looks really loose now
a7 hanging d5 hanging h5 hanging
and always this pretty
strange ambitious time warning okay
if i take a7 now what does he do then
bishop to c7
check
hmm
check
yeah this should be enough also with
the time the time pressure that is good
f7 now
black forfeits on time yeah
yeah this of course was was i think
pretty lucky i simply didn't i didn't
notice that a1 is
was hanging completely but i guess the
position still was was unclear
and after a couple of moves it was
simply good for me because he had so
many weaknesses